Vsauce Kevin here with a message about
your online existence social media is a
venomous snake pit of linguistic
diarrhea and keyboard garbage because no
one can agree on what knowledge is
actually knowledge no matter what the
post or video or tweet or argument is
about no matter what side they're on no
matter what they believe someone else
knows they're wrong they don't know
anything how can two people be both so
confident that they know something when
they've reached totally different
conclusions obviously both can't be
right
right what's weird is that it seems
pretty simple to know something I mean
you just know it you know it because you
have some kind of relevant experience or
you know someone who does and they
transferred that knowledge to you or
maybe you've read something you trust or
you know that what an expert in a
particular field says is valid however
it comes to you that information is an
accurate description of the way the
world is
that's knowledge right right sometimes
the way we tend to think about knowledge
is in terms of justified true belief a
concept that goes back to Plato's
dialogue between Socrates and theaetetus
in 369 BC and was actually refined and
codified by 20th century philosophers
it's a little more modern than it seems
but it's exactly what it sounds like to
know something you need to have
justification for it what sort of
evidence tells you it's right is there
enough of it are the odds in its favor
and it needs to be true is it reality
for you
and for others does it really hold up to
scrutiny truth is pretty weird in that
it's metaphysical it's about how things
are not necessarily what you see we
don't even have to verify something for
it to be true quick-pick heads or tails
go I'm never ever going to look at the
result of this coin flip but half of you
predicted the true outcome and then
you've got to believe it and you have to
recognize it as being true and justified
look here's a very simple example you
look at a clock to find out the time
because clocks tell time you're
justified in thinking a clock is going
to tell you the time the clock says 3:00
p.m. which you believe because it's
always been right for and this is what
clocks do it's true because it's
actually 3:00 p.m. so congratulations
you know it's 3:00 p.m. all of this
makes sense what I've just described is
a formal examination of what we all do
pretty much all the time but I can prove
you're justified true belief your
knowledge can be an illusion for
thousands of years understanding of what
knowledge is was considered edged in
stone case closed
until in 1963 philosopher Edmund Gettier
wrote a short three page paper that
completely smashed the justified true
belief simulation it was such a shift in
how we think about knowledge that
philosopher Alvin Plantinga said in 1993
that knowledge is justified true belief
so we thought from time immemorial then
God said let Gettier be not quite all
was light perhaps but at any rate we
learned we had been standing in a dark
corner wow Gettier claimed that we can
satisfy all three of those conditions
and still not actually know something
let's revisit our clock example we
looked at a clock that read 3 p.m. and
had knowledge it was 3 p.m. because it's
satisfied plato's justified true belief
definition what if the clock was broken
and stuck at 3 p.m.
do you actually know the time from
looking at a broken clock even if it's
accidentally correct no like n oh no not
KN Oh W no no that is justified true
belief without knowledge that is a
Gettier problem or think of it like this
there is a cat in this YouTube video out
in Sherriff cat here I just posed it on
into this two-bit town to restore a bit
of order you see this here wobbling jog
tenderfoots benyard in the hours away
with too much mustard and I aim to set
things straight before the whole Corral
turns into a bag of nails
I haven't been outside in four months
anyway there's a cat in this YouTube
video you know there's a YouTube video
because you're watching me record it
you're on YouTube right now you're
looking at Sheriff cat you're justified
in thinking there's a cat in this video
you can decide it's true with confidence
and you believe what you're seeing
everything here adds up and you are
right there has been a cat in this video
this whole time you are just right for
the wrong reasons and yeah you were
right but did you know it is that
knowledge is that knowledge Luna figured
out what knowledge is no of course it's
not knowledge you knew nothing you had a
justified true belief it was accurate
but it wasn't so even when you're right
how do you know you're not actually
wrong this calls into question the
scientific method what we think we know
about the natural world everything given
the ease and prevalence of Gettier
problems we can't possibly know anything
right hello
wrong well mostly wrong this is how it
actually works okay
as scientists do we have a hypothesis
we wonder if something is true or not
true we propose an experiment if the
experiment supports the hypothesis they
would say well maybe my idea was true
but I could be biased
maybe there's a flaw in my experiment
maybe the electrical current had a
glitch in the midpoint of taking data
yeah but that's exactly the kind of
uncertainty I'm talking about I
experiment again I try to design a
different kind of experiment to test for
the same idea I get a colleague of mine
to test it I get them to come up with a
new kind of experiment I get a
competitor of mine too to try to show
that I'm wrong with an experimental
design of their own and if all those
experiments give approximately the same
answer because there will be statistical
variation
I think it's approximately the same
answer we're onto something ok ok ok so
in science you take what seems to be
knowledge and then start to eliminate
all those other possibilities to distill
what you think you know is emergent in
the methods and tools of science as they
are applied to that question all right
so we learned earth goes around the Sun
that's not gonna later on be shown to be
false ever ever we got that one now you
can ask more refined questions ok what
kind of orbit does it have is it a
perfect circle it's a good approximation
but it's not exactly right so you can
ask deeper questions yes it does go
around the Sun what kind of a circle is
it is it a squash circle is it it
elongated it is it that and you keep
doing this and what you end up doing is
refining the answer to the question to a
level that satisfies your need
in the moment yes so that's how
knowledge builds and expands so maybe
it's not so much what we don't know as
what we keep finding out so you can say
oh we never know anything yes we know a
lot of things will we ever know anything
perfectly well there are certain things
you can ask where you're just counting
things yes you can note perfectly
there's certain crystals where we know
exactly where all the atoms are where
all the atoms are and we can count them
we know exactly how many atoms there are
in a crystal certain crystals yes there
are certain answers that are precise but
if it involves a measurement no you can
it can be ever more refined but there
could be a point where more refinement
just doesn't matter to the aspect of the
answer that you're seeking so in science
we are perfectly content when multiple
experiments agree even if the
Philosopher's isn't even if the
philosopher is distracted by the
possibility that there might be a deeper
truth lurking within the data that we
have accumulated are there a problem
with it I don't have a problem yeah I
guess we can hit a point where we know
as much as we want to or need to and
when we hit the end like that we move on
to something else
science is a continuous journey through
the maze of nature and but not all
information is equally uncertain that's
my only point here and so we know how to
fly we know how wheels work but in all
the other machines and physics we know
how electricity works we've this is
floppy eye we can use a phone I got an
old-fashioned phone here that's why this
works to say we can't really know but we
do know that's why it's why you're
living longer that's why so many things
are different about your life today
then how your ancestors lived because
the methods and tools of science have
been applied to questions that curious
people have asked Fred for the most part
for the betterment of society and for
civilization itself so no I'm not gonna
wallow in some prospect that we can
never know anything no we do and if you
want to think that way just move back to
the cave because that's really where you
belong
yeah I like indoor plumbing hey Neil uh
while I've got you there's a question
that's been killing me for years it's
very very important
you got a question after all that okay
what is it okay ready is a hot dog a
sandwich I have vowed many years ago to
never get into an argument with someone
of the definition of a word all kinds of
people love doing this I remember
growing up is it a gum or is it a candy
is it lighter is it less fillings it's
good I'm saying no I'm not going there
because ideas matter to me more than the
words we come up with to describe that
okay I need to know we need to
categorize this just because brain is is
is but yours but all of our collective
brains want to categorize things and if
something spills out of one category we
fight about weird pull off I'm saying no
I'm not having that thing I'm not having
that fight in fact if you want to go
there just invent a new category call it
the hot dog category okay it's not a
sandwich it's a hot dog get up I'd be
happy with that otherwise no I'm not
spending time arguing please Neil this
is it a naan bread food sitting between
two surfaces of bread it's a sandwich
though
well haha there you have it so this
wasn't even plugged into anything anyway
the Gettier problem exists and knowledge
is a lot more complicated than it seems
excuse me Sheriff ket happy trails
sometimes knowledge is straightforward
and irrefutable sometimes it's murky
sometimes we're right and wrong at the
same time and sometimes we hit the
practical limits of our curiosity and
shouldn't really bother getting any more
granular than that like Neil says at a
certain point it's time to move on till
we decide we need to go back in 1972 WV
Quine who I referenced in the what is a
paradox video wrote an essay
specifically dedicated to the limits of
knowledge he opens it by asking are
there things that man can never know and
Roger Shattuck a writer and literary
professor explored the consequences of
understanding 24 years later in his book
forbidden knowledge including starting
off the entire thing with a seminal
question to the human experience are
there things we should not know and what
about Gettier who inspired a revolution
in how we think about thought
philosopher John L Pollock concluded
that Gettier single-handedly changed the
course of epistemology get ears 92 years
old now he never published another thing
after that paper not a word when asked
why all he said was I have nothing more
to say apparently he also invented the
mic drop it's been another 24 years
since Shaddix book and my answer to all
the questions asked by Shattuck Quine
Gettier and Plato is
I don't know and yes social media is
nuts but the other day I was reading a
thread by Simon de deo he's a professor
at Carnegie Mellon runs the laboratory
for social Minds at the Santa Fe
Institute he was talking about knowledge
and justified true belief and he said
one reason he likes doing science with
others is because they can help him
disprove something he believes more
efficiently than he can himself he said
that works best because we need help in
exploring the unknown if you're walking
in the woods you can either walk towards
a landmark or away walking away for some
reason seems to work better that's what
we're doing all the time were
identifying the known and exploring the
unknown we struggle with imperfect
knowledge and whether it's science
philosophy cats or hot dogs to get to
where we're going sometimes we just need
to walk away and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
so sheriff cat do you arrest like humans
or do you just arrest other cats do us
dogs like how this is working come on
hello hey you can watch more of Neal and
I discussing the boundaries of knowledge
and science over on Startalk and make
sure you subscribe to Startalk while
you're there it is wonderful also the
summer curiosity box has dropped and you
can start thinking now by getting yours
at curiosity box comm it's made by
Vsauce and this is the subscription for
thinkers so basically you buy